he literally would put his hands on my
hip and he would say okay now
i want you to go this way
[Applause]
so when we talk about draymond green one
of the most unique players the nba has
seen he defends he rebounds he assists
he's really the point forward on the
team from a defensive standpoint he's
not selfish as a defender draymond is
great at locking down and he's also a
great help defender too many times
people focus on draymond's personality
but what i focus on is his ability to
guard understand schemes
and then help his teammate and i know
draymond likes to say that he's one of
the best to ever do it but i'm gonna
remind him there was another player hall
of famer his name was dennis johnson and
we called him the soul man dj backing
his way in cartwright the double team
parish the bucket there he is dennis
johnson to the glass o'clock blocked by
dj dj turns the corner
what soul man was great at doing he
would lock you down he would help him
recover he would give back he could
guard the one to two the three to four
to five just like draymond but he wasn't
as bolsterous with his personality as
draymond is had the ultimate compliment
from one of the greatest players in our
era larry bird was the dude larry bird
said this about dennis johnson best
teammate i ever played with now man you
larry bird played with hall of famer
bill walton hall of famer kevin mchale
hall of famer nate archibald hall of
famer robert parish and he said dennis
johnson was the best that's how great a
defender dennis johnson
[Applause]
[Applause]
just to remind you when birds stole the
ball right who ends up making the layup
who has the presence of mind to still be
involved in the play make the cut make
the layup and finish the play off yeah
bird showed the ball but the guy who
made the basket was dennis johnson annie
anderson is blocked by dennis johnson
johnson has the ball restriction
here
[Applause]
the thing that made dennis johnson so
difficult for me as an offensive player
when he was guarding me he was super
strong then hand checking was in he
literally would put his hands on my hip
and he would say okay now i want you to
go this way so i would back up and when
i backed up right he would take his
hands off but then he would spread his
arms out and he had like a seven foot
wingspan so i would go through my stuff
i would think i would be around him so
as i'm going around him he'll be like
got that
being able to use his body his hand
techniques it's almost back then when
you play you had to know judo right you
had to know how to counteract the arm
bar you had to know how to counteract
the hand check if you didn't know a
little judo and understand how to use
your hands you know a guy like dj can
just say okay
come over here nah come back over here
okay
stay right here okay i'll let you go
that's dennis johnson
[Applause]
blocked by johnson how good was that
interception by dennis johnson batted
down by draymond what a play
i make the comparison with dennis
johnson and draymond and if draymond
green wanted to score he could easily be
a 15-20 point scorer in this league but
that's what he focused on and
concentrated on just like dennis johnson
was dennis johnson finals mvp
20 point score phoenix great score then
he goes to the celtics and he goes what
do i need to do to make my team win
draymond green says what do i need to do
to make my team win and that's where
these two to me are very similar
draymond green can have his fingerprints
can be all over the game and he scores
eight points but dennis johnson was the
same way defensively he can lock
everybody down shut everybody down and
you know bird and mikael would score 30
dennis johnson would have eight but at
the end of the game we'd be in the
locker room saying man that dennis
johnson
we gotta figure out something to do with
him
look him up dennis johnson dj miss you
love you